neu paires de collant oui ne9f paires de
collant oui oui effectivement un métier
dangereux vous voulez craquer souvent
oui oui oui souvent souvent bah ce prix
là on peut se permet d' prendre ne paire
il y a pas de problème c'est combien la
paire 390 des voiles les hommes ils aent
ils adorent
[Musique]
ça il est 19h Tati vous dit
bonsoir il est trop tard ferme
désolé je comprends
pas lundi matin depuis la mort de
c'estéonore sa veuve qui garde le
magasin un magasin qui aurait d
s'appeler Tita comme leur fille oui mais
voilà Tita s'était déjà pris alors j a
interverti les deux syllabes
Tita si vous avez unetite marche
bénéfici
vzcoup un tournover et grâce à ça vous
gagnez de l'argent mais ça ne nous
intéresse pas de vendre une grosse pièce
par jour nous préférons vendre 50
petites pièces par jour et puis le monde
vient appelle le monde et quand un
magasin vous vous passez devant si vous
voyez avec beaucoup de monde les gens
disent il y a une affaire à faire nous
entrons si vous voyez un magasin vide
vous n'avez pas envie d'entrer non
plus Tati c'est un temps Tati c'est une
un
monument c'est une
entité et puis ça fait partie intégrante
de notre vie de la vie de la famille
puis je reste la maman vous êtes la
garante de l'esprit alors absolument et
c'est quoi l'esprit Tati l'esprit Tati
c'est vendre
beaucoup le moins cher possible avoir de
toutes petites marge bénéficiaire et
pour faire profiter le plus de gens
possible de notre facilité d'achat et de
notre ça savoir faire je peux y croire à
ce discours humaniste
ça croyons non ça n'a pas d'importance
mais c'est un fait c'est comme ça si ch
quoi qu'il en soit au fil des ans Tati
est devenu une véritable institution on
y vient du monde entier dans cet autobus
des touristes de
Nouvelle-Calédonie qu'est-ce que vous
avez acheté vous des du linge pour mes
enfants c'est beaucoup moins cher
beaucoup moins cher ah
oui Choup il a beaucoup de monde par
rapport à chez nous là il y a beaucoup
moins de
monde il y a pas à demander tu vois tout
de suite avec les mannequins qui sont
là-haut tu vois que ça c'est pour les
garçons ça c'est pour les filles ça
c'est pour les femmes et puis le côté
c'est pour les hommes on peut fouiller
alors c'est un peu facile il a fouillé a
chercher supprimer toutes les barrières
psychologiques qui peuvent repousser des
clients modestes c'était ça l'idée de
Jul
waky comme nous l'a expliqué son fils
Fabien directeur général de la société
ce que voulait son père c'est que tout
se vend comme des patates
ouais ouais c'éit une image c'estàd que
comme des patates c'est c'est un peu
comme au marché quoi c'est toujours ça
c'est comme l'étal d'un d'un épicier
c'est c'est c'est ça le principe de ta
qu'on touche la marchandise il me semble
que quand une fois qu'on a touché la
marchandise on a établi un lien déjà
avec le produit c'estàd que on s'y
attache alors soit on aime soit on aime
pas mais on a déjà établi le premier
lien et la chaussure au début le type
qui Ava installé le magasin c'était dans
des boîte rangé il av des petits sièges
pour s'asseoir avec la vendeuse pour
essayer il est arrivé la veille du
magasin ditz-moi tout ça je veux qu'on
vend les godasses comme des patates
mettez-moi ça dans des tables et céit un
succès immédiat c'est la première fois
qu'on vendrait des chaussures de cette
manière 36 ans après l'ouverture cette
formule attire plus de 20 millions de
personnes qui dépensent en moyenne 70
francs par visite Serge Mathias a 36 ans
marié d'un enfant il est
pasteur j'aime pas trop m'occuper
d'argent j'aime pas trop devoir devoir
faire attention mais on est obligé de
faire attention parce parce que sinon
les fin de mois sont difficiles sont
trop difficiles
donc si j'ai à choisir paire de
chaussures pour mon fils qui fait 300
francs une qui fait 100 francs et que ça
revient exactement au même et bien je je
prendrai celle 100 franc et peu importe
si la marque n'est pas à la hauteur ah
franchement la jupe impeccable ah mais
je dis pas ça chaque année ce grand
bazar achète pour 900 millions de francs
de marchandise les achats c'est le cur
du système c'est là que Tati fait la
différence les acheteurs ils sont une
dizaine issu de la base ils connaissent
parfaitement le magasin et
regarde
ti jamais jamais com combien tu en a là
non laisse tomber ça 2200 pièces tu me
dis ce que tu veux je 55 que du blanc
qu'est-ce que tu veux que je que du
blanc imagine-toi c'est dans la table et
alors tu vas m'en acheter tu en achètes
bien d'habitude attendez attendez il y a
une autre le responsable du rayon
lingerie c'est Monsieur pied des gros
poids vous m'avez fait encore des petits
poids pour la deuxième fois de
balles là c'est
[Musique]
dur Monsieur Pierre est dur mais c'est
la règle du jeu et les fournisseurs la
connaissent ils savent que dans la
négociation ils n'auront pas le dernier
mot mais qu'en revanche ils seront payés
Ruis sur longue et à la
livraison quantité il y a pas de
problème on pe faire un paquet mais sur
be surton on jamais
faitaffre on se désintéresse du coup de
c'est le problème du fournisseur il
s'adapte il s'en va en une formule ça
donne de yeux pour acheter un il pour
vendre
explication on peut penser que c'est
deux pour Acher à
l'achatétier c'est gagner sur le
dose
pas bien acheter pour faire profiter nos
clients et un pour vendre ça c'est là où
y a du
génie c'est que quand on est acheteur et
quand on est à la fois
vendeur on sait on connaî la vente tu
vois quand
[Musique]
pas finalement vous les avez à combien
les slip que vendre la dame 250 au lieu
de 360 il venit d'où de Chine de Chine
de Chine en général ça vient d'où les
sous-vêtements sous-vêtement vienent
marché commun la France bien entendu qui
est grand producteur ha gamme moyenne
gamme et là combien vous en vendez vous
de petit C sous-vêtements les petites
culottes on vend 5 6 millions de petites
culottes par an on doit être le numéro 1
en distribution de petite culotes ah
regarde parce que c'est j'ai peur que ce
soit trop
petit 4 6 8 9 paires ne paires de
collant oui neu paires de collant ou oui
effectivement vous un métier dangereux
vous voulez craquer souvent oui oui oui
souvent souvent bah ce prix là on peut
se permettre d' prendre ne P il y a pas
de problème combien la pire 3,90 des
voiles les hommes ils aiment ils adorent
ça si cette jeune femme en avait acheté
100 pair elle aurait payé un peu moins
de 400 francs pas assez pour obtenir
l'étiquette de groses fiche dans le
langage des caissières ça veut dire gros
client en général les grosses fiches
achètent pour
revendre tu sors les
produits vous achetez en grosse quantité
ouais j'en achète en grosse quantité je
les rend à Dakar à Dakar ouais j'e payer
mes vacances comme ça vous êtes
sénégalais
ouais qu'est-ce que vous achetez par
exemple qui se vend bien à Dakar l decp
c'est bien c'est beau et c'est pas lourd
parce qu'il faut payer le poids et le
billet et la douane
éventuellement quand vous achetez un
article 15 francs ou 8 francs vous le
revendez combien tro fois TR fois ouais
le prix je le prix mon billet d'avion et
mon
bénéf ça ce prix là ouais parce qu'on en
trouve plus cher sur le marché sur place
si à Dakar ou Alger Tati fait un tabac
il est des endroits où ça
coinceen WAKI voulait ouvrir à Nice et à
la défense ce fut deux échecs ni les
commerçants de la place mena ni ceux de
la Grande Arche ne voulit de son
voisinal on voulait pas la défense parce
que la défense ça représente le Paris
EXM moderne la technologie les grands
ensembles comme ça c'est un petit peu le
le manatan Parisien et Tati c'est
déplacé à C endroit-là ça je trouve ça
naz
quoi moi j'aimerais bien que les gettos
tombent non pas pour prendre la
clientèle de la nuie montagne elle va
pas me rapporter plus d'argent je veux
dire c'est pas parce que une cliente qui
gagne 100000 francs par mois elle va
acheter la même chose que celle qui
gagne 4000 francs par mois elle va
toujours payer ses colollant 2 francs 90
ça va rien m'amener de plus mais
j'aimerais qu'on reconnaisse les êtres
humains qui achètent chez moi et qui
sont fiers devenir chez moi je veux dire
les les populations de l'Est ou
d'Afrique et qui considèrent Tati comme
un patrimoine français je veux dire qui
sont fiers de qui rentrent chez eux qui
disent tu as vu ce que j'ai acheté chez
Tay et c'est ils pourront jamais acheter
ça chez Chanel et ils s'en foutent
quelque
part
ah
Sylvie vous allez souvent chez Tati oui
j'y vais souvent tous les vendredis en
général vous avez un
budget budget je peux pas compter mon
budget parce que je dépense
trop comment à vous dépenser trop faites
pas attention non parce que pour une
femme soit belle il faut bien dépenser
il faut qu'elle soit coquette pour les
hommes j'espère et en général c'est
comme ça il faut dépenser quoi vous
touchez beaucoup vous quand vous êtes
chez Tati pour voir la matière ah oui je
touche beaucoup ça c'est sûr je touche
beaucoup pourquoi parce que premièrement
mon métier c'est pareil que Tati je suis
dans l'alimentation c'est presque pareil
et quand je reçois mes marchandises je
touche beaucoup pouvoir et pour dire à
mes clientes alors c'est pour ça chez
Tatti je touche beaucoup c'est la même
chose moi je
trouve vous choisissez avec les doigts
alors pas avec les yeux
vous avec les deux avec les deux avec
les
de vous en foutez des prix non non non
non moi je tiens compte des prix jeis
plutôt rationnel dans mes
dépenses je gagne pas déjà assez
beaucoup alors si je tiens pas compte
des prix je pourrais pas acheter pour
moi et pour ma femme et pour mon enfant
c'est pourquoi Tati pour moi ça
représente beaucoup de choses parce que
je trouve les prix les plus bas et puis
ça me permet d'avoir tout pour nous
trois combien vous gagnez vous par mois
ah ça je le cach pour moi d'accord Mo et
combien vous dépensez pour habiller
votre
famille bon ma femme déjà
dépensière
je peux pas dire combien elle dépense
mais moi c'est pas beaucoup c'est la
plus chè
celle-ci entre les conseils de sa mère
et les réflexions des clients Carole ne
sait plus très bien tuimes bien ça moi
j'aime bien
ça j'aime bien ça et tout ce qu' essay
oui tu RVER toute la nuit ene la nuit tu
vas RVER longtemp Mar elle est là depuis
21 ans et si j' dire au
mour vous me parliez des robes blanches
de marié oui en me disant que ça servait
pas seulement au mariage non pour des
décès aussi également surtout pour les
personnes africaines c'est-à-dire
c'est-à-dire c'est qu'on achète des
robes de mari oui pour les décès oui
pour moi c'est pas c'est pas la première
sera pas la dernière c'est une question
d'habitude mais c'est vrai que ça choque
au départ mais on s'y fait à la longue
quand vous sortez pour le
bisou
la responsable du rayon robe de mari
c'est madame Monique 36 ans de service
va se perdre dans Madame Monique parce
que tout le monde vous appelle madame
Monique ici vous pouvez m'expliquer
comment vous pouvez vendre ici une robe
qu'on vend ailleurs 5000 francs 1000
francs bah voilà on on achète peut-être
mieux qu'ailleurs on achète de très
grosses quantités déjà et
puis on modifie on fait des modèles pour
nous on cherche des qualités on discute
tout se discute le prix de façon le prix
de la matière si on achète de grosses
quantités on peut discuter le
fournisseur peut discuter le prix de la
matière donc c'est normal qu'on obtienne
des prix sur la quantité à contrar les
autres discutent pas alors c'est à
croire je peux pas la faire passer moins
de
105 non non c'est un gros eff regardez
20 fr de moin c'est
pas non
croyez-moi chaque année madame Monique
vend 25000 robes de marié pour
l'essentiel elle les fait fabriquer au
Sentier un quartier de Paris composé de
quatre arrondissements et où sont
regroupé 5000 entreprises
textile chiffre d'affaires global
environ 55 milliards de francs en
général des entrepreneurs discrets qui
n'aiment guère avouer être marié avec tê
allons là ou mettre un motif la raison
elle est simple oui voilà on fait des
prix à malamonique que nous ne faisons
pas à nos à nos autres clients mais
madame Monique est une privilégiée chez
nous vu d'abord son chiffre le nombre de
robes ENF alors donc on ne voudrait pas
que nos clients le sachent
oui mais veut voir le truc chez les
wakis que l'on surnomme les banquers du
textile on paye cash les fournisseurs on
ne fait pas de pub et on ne connaî pas
le
crédit jamais nous n'avons empruné un
centime à une banque si bien qu'une fois
il y avait la GR je crois la BNP
bar et la BNP n' pas d'argent pour payer
le personnel je où ils sont venus
demander de l'argent à Monsieur W c'est
Monsieur W qui le donné de l'argent de
la recette de la journé pour pouvoir
payer le personnel je sais pas je trouve
ça
superbe le crédit pas question en
revanche les voleurs dans le magasin
c'est pas vraiment mal d'ailleurs à ce
propos monsieur Jules disait laissezles
venir à moi ce sont mes cents magasin
passa quand vous AZ beaucoup de client
dans un magasin les voleurs ils ont
peuvent mieux se cacher et donc mieux
voler et si vous n'avez personne dans le
magasin vous n'avez pas de voleurs non
plus donc s'il y a des voleurs c'est
qu'il y a du monde c'est
bon je vous ai vu mettre les bousons sur
vous oh là là tu as vu quelle confusion
vu moi je t'ai vu et toi je t'ai vu vous
deux je vous ai vu qu'on vous l'exlique
éc votre attention s'il vous plaît
mesdames messieurs aidez-nous à faire
échec au P pocket surveille bon enfin
c'est une formule parce qu'il y a quand
même un gros service de sécurité une
vingtaine de personnes les clients de
Tati des ouvriers bien sûr mais aussi
des cadres comme Françoise zimer
tatinophil à
fond euh ça j'ai dû payer 50 francs
c'est chez Tati ça ça aussi c'est Tati
tiens ça c'était ça ça c'est Tati alors
c'est la la grande marque de chez Tati
c'est euh la rue est à nous alors je
l'ai dû le payer 30 francs c'est griffé
Tati en plus alors là vous parlez des
griffes c'est griffé Tati puisque c'est
leur sigle ça me gêne pas du tout de le
mettre au contraire ça fait un peu de
provocation j'aime
bien provocateur d'avouer s'habiller à
Barb quand on a les moyens marieck
confirme certains clients ont un peu
honte et ben ils ont des sacs il sort
des sacs mettons je sais pas moi des
sacs des galeries la faillette ou du BHV
il déchir les sacs tactil ils mettent
les achats dans les autres sacs et puis
jettent les sacs
tactil un petit conseil si vous
n'assumez pas évitez de prendre des sacs
transparent dans la famille de Carole
qui va devenir madame roelin on est loin
de ce genre de manège Janine Pascal et
les autres se moquent des étiquettes Mar
sûrement qu'il enevient pas de sentir
posé contre son bras une petite main
aussi légère pourvu qu'il est la bonne
manière pour la conduire comme une amie
tout là-bas jusqu'au bout de la vie pour
un peu j'irai lui parler je lui dirai
puisque tu as la chance de posséder un
tel trésor fais attention joue pas au
fort quand c'est dans les mains que ça
vous passe il suffit d'un rien pour que
ça
casse regarde là avec son voile blanc
c'est comme un ange tant qu'elle est
belle mais un an V que ça a des ailes ça
peut facilement le camp tche de
la tenir contre ton cœur et si lu fait
une belle musique comm elle trouvera ça
magnifique elle en écoutera pas
ailleurs mais qu'est-ce que j'ai
raconter moi c'est pas moi le père du
marié vaut mieux reculer fa la place
saluer c'est la joie qui
passe en 1948 quand j a ouvert son
premier magasin à Barb il avait 50 m
[Musique]
car y